My name is Natalija Vladisavljević.
I am working in the field of dance choreography,
writing for dance,
leading workshops.
As a choreographer,
I find inspiration in my head.
I’m inspired by the space,
the people, the stage...
A choreographer thinks
about what she'll write,
which means that when I get inspired
to write something about myself,
I must consider what is it I want to
write about, what am I thinking about,
and only then do I start
gathering information
and actions on the stage.
That's how a choreographer
works on how to organise herself.
For my new show called
Dance in the 21st Century,
I’m working with my dancers
on choreographic, graphical,
and music scores,
for the instructions of contemporary dance.
When I write the scores,
I imagine what my show would look like.
I think about many different topics
and choreographic segments.
And once I put it all together
and wrap it up, the show is ready.
As a choreographer, I think about the lights,
costumes, space, dramaturgy.
Besides being a choreographer,
I alsolead contemporary dance workshops.
I sometimes write very precise instructions,
and sometimes I ask them to work
through improvisation, the way they like.
I need to see their choreographies
at the end of the workshop,
and then we talk about them.
Witch Dance (Hexentanz)
is a contemporary dance
with a lot of elements for movements
and I imagine myself in a way that I can,
with my own body,
initiate my own dance
and that is the way to maintain my strength.
Well, I chose Hexentanz, "The Witch Dance",
because it was important for me
to work in this contemporary dance,
like Mary Wigman.
And I chose that one
because Mary Wigman and I
have the same facial expression.
Yes, I wrote a libretto,
and I wrote it down as I imagined it,
I imagined how it would look.
So, I started
imagining, imagining, imagining...
And I wrote that story.